[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sallyis
Welt ihr seht schon an meiner Umgebung
ich stehe heute vor dem Schloss
Transsylvanien und zwar wurde ich von
Sony und Columbia angeschrieben ob ich
denn nicht eine Motivtorte kreieren
möchte für den neuen Kinofilm Hotel
Transsylvanien Teil 2 ich habe mir
bereits mit Samira den ersten Teil
angeschaut und zwar geht's in dem Film
darum dass einfach es gibt Monster und
Vampire in dem Schloss Transsylvanien
und die haben furchtbar Angst vor
Menschen aber es gelingt dann doch einem
Menschen in dieses Hotel einzudringen
und dann knüpft er eben Kontakt zu
Draculas Tochter und sie verleben sich
ineinander und das war dann eben der
erste Teil und jetzt im zweiten Teil
geht's darum dass die beiden eben ein
Kind bekommen und dieses Kind ist halb
mench halb Vampir aber Dracula möchte
natürlich dass dieser dass dieses
Enkelkind ein richtiger Vampir wird und
wer das anstellt das schauen wir uns mal
ganz kurz im Trailer
an seit Jahrhunderten haben Monster und
Menschen in getrennten Welten gelebt bis
ein Ort was ist das für ein Essen das
beiß ja das ist unser Menü mit bis alles
veränderte chuldigung zieh den Schläger
im Treffmoment nach oben das geht ein
netten
[Musik]
Topspin hurra mein Enkelsohn die
Blutlinie der Draculas ist gesichert
bist du sicher er ist ein Vampir guck
dir die Haare an er könnte ein Mensch
sein nur über meine
Leiche danke dass du auf Dennis aufasst
während wir im Urlaub sind weißt du noch
wie videochatten geht ja ja mit dem
Handy und den Knöpfen und der känerei
und jetzt müssen wir dem kleinen
beibringen wie man ein Monster wird Blob
da ist kein Platz tut mir leid
Mann schlag dir das aus dem Kopf Frank
zeigt uns jetzt mal wie er Menschen
erschrägt
Frankenstein du bist der Hammer dürfen
wir ein Foto machen ja gern eine kleine
selfieummer echt
jetzt blobby geht's dir gut da
[Musik]
draußen ihm geht's gut er ist blobby
weißt du wer den kleinen hinkriegen
würde
Flat bitte töte mich nicht sprechendes
Klopapier s ja ganz was neues
[Musik]
sind wir endlich alle
soweit tut mir leid Lobby wir wollten
dich wirklich früher
rufen okay Jungs Plan B ich spring auf
gib
Gas ist das EU
Ernst jetzt habt ihr einen Versuch von
Graf Dracula gesehen wie er aus seinem
Enkelkind einen waschechten Vampir
machen möchte
habt ihr das auch gerade gehört oh mein
[Musik]
Gott hab ihr Angst bekommen also ich
habe Angst bekommen vor Samira und wir
zwei machen uns mit unseren 3dbrillen
dann ins Kino und zwar kommt der
Kinofilm am 15.10 in alle Kinos den
werden wir uns auf jeden Fall anschauen
mit dem Papa tut die fre schon richtig
drauf und ihr könnt euch auch freuen
denn am Ende dieses Videos gibt's ein
kleines Gewinnspiel da gibt's ein
gewinnerpaket das werde ich dann
verlosen und ich würde jetzt mal sagen
wir zwei gehen wieder in unsere Küche
und ich zeige euch dann wie man diese
leckere Torte backt du bist so
gruselig hier habe ich jetzt drei
schwarze Böden gebacken und zwar sind es
schokoladenböden im Durchmesser von 26
cm hier habe ich zwei kleinere mit 20 cm
das sind helle orangenböden und die habe
ich auch orange eingefärbt ich habe hier
etwas Kirschsaft und Orangensaft zum
Tränken eine orangenbuttercreme und eine
zartbitterganache und die ganzen Rezepte
die ich dafür benutzt habe die findet
ihr bereits in meinen cake basic Videos
und ich habe jetzt einfach diesen
schokoladeng Grundteig mit etwas
schwarzer lebensmittelfarbpaste
eingefärbt und den orangenen einfach mit
etwas Orangenschale aufgepeppt und mit
rot und gelb
eingefärbt und jetzt muss ich für die
tipsi Torte zuerst einmal die Böden
befüllen und dann stapeln und ich starte
jetzt einfach mal direkt mit dem kleinen
ich habe jetzt hier so ein cakeboard das
habe ich jetzt schon mal benutzt aber
ich brauche es jetzt auch nur ganz kurz
leg mir das
[Musik]
dahin dann kann ich da näm ich den
ersten Boden drauf setzen aber nicht
ankleben denn später wird es nicht das
richtige cakeboard bleiben ich stürze es
jetzt einfach mal
drauf
und jetzt muss der Boden
durchgeschnitten werden aber nicht
wgerecht sondern etwas angeschrägt damit
ich später diese schiefe Optik
[Musik]
hinbekomme und jetzt habe ich mir das
hier außen markiert das heißt hier von
mir aus rechts fange ich jetzt an die
Torte von oben nach unten zu
[Musik]
schneiden mit einem tortenretter könnt
ihr den Boden dann
wegnehmen und den Tränke ich jetzt mit
bisschen Orangensaft aber nicht so sehr
denn der Teig ist sowieso richtig
saftig und der wird jetzt mit der
orangen bututtercreme
gefüllt
jetzt kommt der zweite Boden jetzt auch
wieder drauf aber ebenso dass die hohe
Stelle auch an die hohe Stelle wieder
zurückkommt dann habe ich jetzt hier
nämlich diese schräge
drin den zweiten Boden schneide ich
jetzt wagerecht durch der kann ruhig
gerade bleiben denn der andere ist jetzt
schon schräg
[Musik]
genug und der wird jetzt auch getränkt
und mit Buttercreme
[Musik]
gefüllt
ich habe jetzt hier die rän noch ein
Biss bisschen ausgefüllt mit der
Buttercreme um sie zu stabilisieren und
die Torte muss jetzt erstmal in den
Kühlschrank damit sie fest wird und in
der Zeit kann ich jetzt schon mal die
zweite Torte
stapeln die zweite Möglichkeit die
Kuchenböden schräg zu schneiden ist mit
dieser tortensäge und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier den einen Draht einfach
weggenommen und den Draht hier unten
einmal auf hoch und einmal auf tief
gestellt da müsst ihr dann einfach
schauen dass es eben von der Höhe her
passt und dann kann ich ihn so jetzt
einmal durchschneiden
[Musik]
und dieser wird jetzt auch getränkt und
zwar mit etwas Kirschsaft und mit einer
Zartbitter ganase
[Musik]
gefüllt
die beiden Torten müssen jetzt erstmal
gut durchkühlen damit ich sie später
noch in Form schneiden kann deswegen
stelle ich sie jetzt für etwa eine
Stunde in den Kühlschrank und die
Zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
nutzen um ein bisschen Deko
vorzubereiten ich habe mir jetzt eine
Zeichnung gemacht damit ich einfach so
einen groben Überblick habe wie ich die
Torte dekorieren möchte und vor allem
was für Dekoelemente ich machen möchte
und das habe ich mir jetzt hier
aufgezeichnet und nehmen das so als
Vorlage und für die Dekoration brauche
ich dann einfach folgende Zutaten und
zwar habe ich hier etwas
modellierschokolade in verschiedenen
Farben etwas fondon ich brauche
Blütenpaste hier habe ich bäckerstärke
drin
lebensmittelfarbpasten und etwas CMC
Pulver das ist Zellulose Pulver lässt
dann den fondon etwas fester werden und
gut austrocknen und für meine Hände
brauche ich etwas Kokosfett und ich
möchte jetzt hier zuerst die Kürbisse
Formen und dafür habe ich jetzt gelben
und roten von da gemischt das habe ich
jetzt schon gemacht und vorbereitet
damit dieses orange entsteht und habe
einfach von dem Zellulose Pulver mit
eingeknetet und da könnt ihr einfach so
pro 100 g etwa ein Viertel Teelöffel
cncpulver nehmen aber man merkt es
einfach an der Konsistenz also nicht so
viel nehmen und es jetzt gut
einkneten jetzt habe ich mir da so ein
kleines Stück entnommen Form das zu
einer
Kugel und die drücke ich jetzt so ein
bisschen
platt und kann jetzt mit einem
Modellierwerkzeug hier an der Seite noch
so Streifen
[Musik]
Eindrücken
und jetzt kommt hier oben ein kleines
Loch hinein da werde ich jetzt nämlich
den Stengel reinstecken und den habe ich
mir bereits aus grün und schwarz gefärbt
also ich habe grün und schwarz gemischt
und Form jetzt daraus so ein kleines
Stückchen
[Musik]
und diese kleine Kugel könnt ihr dann
einfach etwas länglich
formen und mit bisschen zuckerkleber
drinnen ankleben und das Rezept für den
zuckerkleber bekommt ihr einfach auf
meinem
Blog und bevor ich die Kürbisse jetzt
weiter verarbeite muss ich sie erstmal
antrocknen lassen und jetzt stelle ich
einfach in derzeit schon mal die
restlichen
[Musik]
her aus grauer Modelliermasse mache ich
jetzt noch ein paar Grabsteine da habe
ich mir jetzt eine Schablone bereits
ausgedruckt und ausgeschnitten und die
LE ich jetzt hier drauf und schneid drum
herum und damit das Ganze so ein
bisschen alten Effekt bekommt ritze ich
jetzt hier einfach mit etwas
Modellierwerkzeug noch ein bisschen
Strukturen mit
ein
[Musik]
und damit die Steine jetzt ein bisschen
Aussehen jetzt mit den Fingern hier die
Ecken so ein bisschen
abrunden und dann einfach mit einem
Werkzeug ein bisschen Struktur
reinbringen also entweder macht man das
auch mit so einem
Modellierwerkzeug oder ich habe jetzt
hier so ein bordürenformer und den
drücke ich jetzt einfach leicht
[Musik]
ein und jetzt stelle ich noch andere
Grabsteine her dafür nehme ich mir so
einen eckigen Ausstecher könnt man jetzt
aber auch ganz einfach mit einem Messer
einfach zurecht
schneiden und die steche ich jetzt hier
kurz
[Musik]
aus und damit sie jetzt nicht so
quadratisch werden steche ich hier noch
mal ein Teil
[Musik]
weg dann wird es jetzt wieder
strukturiert
und wer möchte kann jetzt sogar noch ein
paar Buchstaben hier reinrücken und zwar
habe ich da so Buchstaben die man eben
Stempeln kann die muss man sich hier
einzeln
wegmachen und dann hier in diese
Vorrichtung reindrücken oder
reinschieben und jetzt kann ich die hier
drauf
drücken
[Musik]
und so mache ich jetzt noch ein paar und
lass s alle noch gut
durchrocknen als nächstes formme ich
jetzt hier noch so ein paar Kerzen und
die sehen zwar aufwendig aus aber es
sind ganz einfach ihr braucht einfach
ein kleines Stück Blütenpaste oder
Modelliermasse nehme ich jetzt weiß dann
formme ich daraus ein langes
[Musik]
Stück
das drücke ich hier unten schön flach
und oben formme ich einfach so ein
kleines Loch
rein jetzt braucht ihr da natürlich für
die Flamme so ein bisschen Verstärkung
dann nehme ich jetzt einen Draht dazu
und da müsst natürlich wenn die Torte
gegessen wird dann auch sagen dass da
eben Draht mit drin steckt damit keiner
die Kerzen auf istst der wird da
reingesteckt jetzt formt ihr noch aus
gelb und orange eine kleine Flamme
[Musik]
als nächstes möchte ich jetzt noch ein
Aufsteller machen als Mond und da habe
ich mir jetzt weiße Blütenpaste 10 mm
dick ausgerollt und stech da jetzt ein
Kreis aus und weil ich jetzt auch nicht
so einen großen ausstcher habe nehme ich
jetzt einfach diese Dose ihr könnt auch
ein Teller nehmen oder ein Glas z.B oder
ein
Schälchen und damit ich das dann auch
auf die Torte drauf stellen kann habe
ich jetzt zwei schaschlspieße die habe
ich ein bisschen gekürzt und die tauche
ich jetzt in etwas
zuckerkleber und steck die jetzt da
unten
rein und dann einfach die Fingerabdrücke
wieder ein bisschen
Wegrollen und das muss dann eben
mindestens einen Tag
rohen damit schön aushärtet
als nächstes wird jetzt noch das
Hotelschild gemacht und dafür habe ich
mir weiße Blütenpaste ganz dünn
ausgerollt und schneid da jetzt einfach
ein Schild
zurecht und das mache ich jetzt heute
auch schon damit es durchtrocknen
[Musik]
kann was macht wir denn da aus aus hier
alle die tortten sind jetzt abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich sie noch in Form
schneiden und zwar ist ja jetzt die Form
so zylindermäßig aber ich möchte so ein
bisschen nach unten verengen und
deswegen muss ich die noch zurecht
schneiden die Torte hat ja jetzt 20 cm
im Durchmesser und ich habe jetzt so
eine cakeboard Platte die hat 15 cm im
Durchmesser und dies da jetzt oben drauf
also hier ein bisschen
Gage dann bleibt nämlich die Torte auch
schön dran
kleben und die setze ich jetzt hier
mittig
drauf das ist jetzt der Boden und jetzt
muss die Torte nur noch umgedreht
[Musik]
werden die Platte oben die sitzt da
jetzt locker die lasse ich jetzt aber
mal drauf dann kann ich nämlich hier die
Torte immer so ein bisschen festhalten
und jetzt habe ich hier so ein kleines
Backblech drunter und kann da die
Kuchenkrümel reinfallen
lassen jetzt wird einfach von oben nach
unten geschnitten bis ich da unten das
cakeboard wieder sehe also hier und oben
habe ich ja das große cakeboard das
heißt die Torte verläuft auch gleich
wirklich in dem
Winkel
[Musik]
und die Reste hier die schmeißt die
nicht weg sondern das ist jetzt die
perfekte Grundlage für cakeepps denn ihr
habt ihr jetzt den Kuchenteig und die
Creme und die könnt jetzt ganz ganz gut
zu Cakepops verarbeiten und wenn einfach
nur bisschen Creme fehlt könnt ein
bisschen Creme hinzufügen oder z.B ein
bisschen Marmelade oder
Gase und jetzt wird die Torte mit der
garanache bestrichen einfach damit jetzt
zuerst mal die Krümel gebunden werden
deswegen jetzt erstmal nur eine dünne
Schicht dann stelle ich sie kalt in der
Zeit mache ich die zweite Torte und dann
bestreiche ich sie noch mal richtig mit
der
[Musik]
Ganache
bevor ich jetzt die untere Etage auch
mit kanage einstreiche muss ich oben
jetzt erstmal so so eine Fläche
zurechtchneiden wo ich dann die obere
Torte eben drauf setzen kann ohne dass
sie dann eben später runter kppt und
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier noch mal
ein Kickboard ihr könnt aber auch ein
Teller nehmen z.B und es hat die Größe
von der oberen Torte eben der untere
Umfang lege ich mir jetzt hier mittig
drauf und zeichne einmal drum
herum und die Fläche wird jetzt so ein
bisschen
weggeschnitten
[Musik]
gerade
und jetzt muss die Fläche auch noch mal
mit ganach bestrichen werden und dann
eben noch die komplette Torte glatt
gestrichen
[Musik]
werden
die Torten sind jetzt beide glatt
gestrichen und auch schön kalt und ich
habe jetzt hier schon mal Fondor
vorbereitet und zwar habe ich jetzt 2 kg
blauen Fondor mit 250 g schwarzem vondor
verknetet und habe das jetzt auch schon
mal weich geknetet und jetzt wird es
schön ausgerollt dieses Mal allerdings
nicht so dünn wie sonst also ich rol den
jetzt schon so 4 mm etwa aus damit er
dann beim überziehen eben nicht so
[Musik]
reißt und ich habe übrigens den Fondor
nicht ganz durchgeknetet und das sieht
man jetzt auch hier ich habe jetzt hier
so einen schönen Marmore Effekt und dann
sieht man eben dieses hellblau so ein
bisschen und mit dem dunklen Blau das
vermischt sich dann ganz toll den vondor
Rolle ich jetzt auf den ausrollstab
auf dann kann ich die Torte hier
platzieren und die jetzt mit etwas
backtrenpray einfetten einfach damit der
vondor gleich drauf klebt und keine
Luftbläschen
entstehen das könnt jetzt auch so ein
bisschen verteilen damit einfach überall
etwas backtrinpray dran ist vor allem da
unten
und jetzt den von dort drüber
ausrollen und ich habe den jetzt nicht
ganz so dün ausgerollt damit er jetzt
beim runterformen eben nicht reißt weil
die Torte jetzt nicht gerade runter geht
sondern so nach innen und da ist es
einfach schwieriger die Falten jetzt
glatt zu
[Musik]
bekommen
jetzt werden noch die Ränder mit dem
tortengletter glatt
[Musik]
gemacht
die Torten sind jetzt im Kühlschrank ich
habe jetzt eine Nacht gewartet die
Torten sind schön fest die Dekoration
ist fest geworden und ich werde jetzt
die Dekoration noch ein bisschen
verfeinern und ausbessern und etwas
Struktur mit reingeben und später setze
ich einfach die Torte mit den
Dekorationselementen zusammen ich werde
jetzt direkt anfangen mit den
Grabsteinen und zwar sind die ja wie
gesagt schön ausgehärtet und ich habe
jetzt hier so ein paar Pulverfarben und
zwar in schwarz und rot und so ein
dunkleres rot und mit den Pulverfarben
kann ich jetzt die Grabsteine so ein
bisschen ausmalen das mache ich jetzt
einfach ganz
trocken und bepuder die so ein bisschen
[Musik]
damit
und mit so einem lebensmittelstift könnt
ihr dann z.B noch die Schrift
[Musik]
Nachfahren
jetzt bekommen die Kürbisse noch
gruselige Gesichter und das ma ich jetzt
mit einem
lebensmittelfarbstift einfach hier vorne
zwei Augen und ein Mund
[Musik]
aufmalen
und dann bepudere ich auch die Kürbisse
so ein bisschen mit dunkelrot und
schwarz damit ihr auch so ein bisschen
den 3deekt noch verstekt
[Musik]
bekommen
als nächstes werde ich jetzt das Schild
bemalen und das möchte ich jetzt erstmal
abpudern mit etwas schwarz und dann
werde ich es eben
[Musik]
beschriften
und zum Beschriften nehme ich jetzt hier
diese silberne Farbe und die könnt jetzt
entweder vermischen mit etwas Alkohol
oder mit etwas Palmin z.B was vorher
verflüssigt
[Musik]
wurde
als nächstes werde ich noch den
fertigstellen und dafür bepuder ich ih
einfach noch mal ein bisschen mit etwas
Gold und
[Musik]
Schwarz und jetzt mal ich wieder mit
flüssiger pulverfar
ein paar Fledermäuse
[Musik]
drauf
jetzt kann ich die Torte zusammensetzen
und ich brauche jetzt noch ein bisschen
Kleber und ich mache mir da jetzt ein
Royal Icing also eine
eiweißpritzglasur und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier schon mal drei Esslöffel
Puderzucker also drei gehäufte und
nehmen einen halben Esslöffel eiweißpul
pul dann brauche ich nämlich kein rohes
Ei benutzen und füge jetzt ein bisschen
Wasser mit rein und das verrühre ich
jetzt
miteinander und dann wird das hier so
eine klebrige Masse jetzt habe ich hier
schon mal ein cakeboard mit schwarzem
fonderor eingedeckt und einfach vorher
CMC Kleber mit drauf gegeben damit es
auch hebt und jetzt streiche ich hier so
ein bisschen von dieser
eiweißspritzklasur drauf könnt man jetzt
aber auch ganz normalen zuckerkleber
benutzen
[Musik]
dann kommt direkt die Torte mit
drauf am besten
mittig und damit ich jetzt gleich die
obere Torte draufszen kann und die eben
durch ihr Gewicht nicht einsackt muss
ich jetzt hier noch so Verstärkungen
einbauen und zwar nehme ich da jetzt
cakeepop
Stiele und steck die in die
Torte
so muss ich jetzt aber erst zurecht
schneiden und dafür markiere ich mir das
jetzt hier mit so einem
lebensmittelstift und kann jetzt so etwa
fünf Stäbe zurecht
[Musik]
schneiden
und jetzt setze ich die zweite Torte
einfach noch
[Musik]
drauf die Torte habe ich jetzt noch mal
kühl gestellt und kann jetzt noch ein
bisschen die enddekoration vorbereiten
und zwar möchte ich auf der unteren
Etage so ein Schloss machen also dieses
Hotel transsylvania und habe dafür schon
schwarze
modelliierchokolade etwas weich geknetet
und werde die jetzt ausrollen und die
dann so zweidimensional eben auf die
Torte dann gleich
[Musik]
ankleben hier unten schneide ich jetzt
gerade
ab und markiere mir jetzt so ungefähr 15
cm denn so breit möchte ich in etwa das
Schloss gleich
machen und die obere Grenze markiere ich
mir jetzt auch denn die Dekoration darf
jetzt nicht höher als die Torte selbst
sein und das habe ich halt vorher
ausgemessen jetzt skizziere ich hier so
ein bisschen das
[Musik]
Schloss
da schneide ich jetzt einmal drum
[Musik]
herum
und jetzt Rolle ich mir immer wieder
etwas dünnere Stücke aus und schneid sie
aus und kleb sie dann drüber damit hier
so ein kleiner 3D Effekt
[Musik]
entsteht und jetzt werde ich noch mit
Pulverfarben dieses Schloss
[Musik]
bepudern als nächstes bastle ich jetzt
noch das Schild für Hotel transyvanien
fertig und dafür nehme ich meine Fondant
Presse und diese verschiedenen Aufsätze
hier und zuerst formme ich jetzt hier
diesen langen Strang da nehme ich jetzt
hier dieses
Sechseck und kann das hier unten einfach
ausdrehen
dann wechsel ich den Vorsatz aus und
Form noch die anderen
[Musik]
Teile
und das beputuch jetzt noch mit so einem
Bronzeton und dann lasse ich das hier
einfach lien und kümmer mich gleich
wieder um die
Torte
[Musik]
und jetzt werde ich die ganzen
Dekoelemente mit etwas zuckerkleber auf
die Torte anbringen und noch mit etwas
Pulverfarbe die Torte
[Musik]
ausdekorieren
so sieht jetzt unsere fertige Torte aus
gefällt sie dir ja und ich habe noch
eine Karte dafür ja also mir gefällt die
Torte auch und ich würde jetzt sagen wir
schauen noch mal ganz kurz einen kleinen
Trailer an dann kommt ihr noch mal
richtig auf den Geschmack des Films und
vor allen Dingen gibt's da bestimmt auch
Hinweise für das folgende Gewinnspiel im
Hotel Transsylvanien gibt's Nachwuchs
ich bin Großvater bist du sicher dass er
ein Vampir ist Paps nur ein kleiner Kar
chick wow diesen Herbst ich werde dem
kleinen beibringen wie mE ein Monster
wird helfen Sie ihm oh der zum knel ein
Vampir zu werden wer ist bereit zu
fliegen ich ich
ich er fliegt nicht wisst ihr was er
fliegt wirklich
nicht noch mal noch mal Hotel
Transylvanien 2 in 3D das war jetzt voll
lustig gell ja ich glaub der zweite Teil
wird genauso gut wie der erste Teil wir
lassen uns überraschen auf jeden Fall
kamen euch vielleicht ein paar Stimmen
bekannt vor also synchronisiert wurden
die Stimmen unter anderem von Palina
roschinski von Andreas borani und
moratan das ist der Typ von Bulli der
Grieche der im den Griechen spielt dann
war es noch Nora von waldstettten und
Didi Hall also das dürften all Begriff
sein ich denke auch auf jeden Fall
möchte ich euch jetzt noch kurz das
gewinnerpaket vorstellen und zwar habe
ich hier so ein kleines Set bekommen und
möchte euch das kurz zeigen also zu
gewinnen gibt's diese kleine süße
Fledermaus dies eine Kuscheltier Samira
will sie eigentlich gar nicht mehr gehen
lassen dann hier ein toller Turnbeutel
oder auch einfach so eine Tasche ein
Rucksack mit zwei Flügeln dran genau
Samira zeig mal hier noch ein Mäppchen
mit Inhalt und dieses große Filmposter
das größer ist als Samira könnt ihr euch
dann gerne in euer Zimmer z.B hängen
oder einfach verschenken und was ihr
dafür tun müsst be beantwortet mir
einfach die Frage wie heißt denn das
Enkelkind von Dracula also in dem
Trailer haben wir es auch ganz kurz
gehört und ich denke da kommt ihr auf
jeden Fall auf die Lösung ihr dürft mir
das gerne einfach in die Kommentare
schreiben bei Youtube bei Facebook bei
Instagram ihr dürft auch gerne unser
Video teilen wenn es euch gefallen hat
und Samira wird sich dann den Gewinner
herausziehen einen Gewinner und den
geben wir einfach schriftlich bekannt
das heißt entweder auf Youtube auf
Instagram oder auf Facebook wird dann
der Gewinner direkt kontaktiert und
bekommt dann dieses Set zugeschickt und
das Gewinnspiel läuft jetzt noch bis zum
nächsten Mittwoch da werden wir das
Auslosen Sam zeigt noch mal die
Geschenke und ja ich freue mich dass ihr
eingeschaltet habt und natürlich ganz
wichtig es gibt auf der offiziellen
Filmseite von Hotel Transsylvanien 2
noch weitere Schminkvideos und Schmink
Tutorials und auch noch ganz viele
Rezeptvorschläge falls ihr z.B eine
Halloween Party machen wollt und da
einfach so ein paar Rezeptideen braucht
und den Link dazu findet ihr einfach
unten in meiner Infobox das sind auch
noch alle weiteren Informationen und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel Glück beim
Gewinnspiel und freue mich dass ihr
eingeschaltet habt bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüssü komm wir gehen jetzt die Oma
erschreckenuu
[Musik]
ciao
hat ihr Mamas Kanal noch nicht abonniert
aber jetzt